today i'm going to talk about how to
close your round by building community
through storytelling with your investors
i think this is a perfect follow-up to
andrew's presentation so i'm looking
forward to diving in but first a bit
about myself
and my company i'm the ceo co-founder of
soul savvy which
really in its simplest form uh right now
is a slack community for people who have
a common interest
and passion for sneakers to give some
color on our last raise
our seed round was originally for 1
million and then it became 1.5 million
and at the very end we squeezed in the
final check for half a million bringing
our total
to a two million dollar party round this
included 33 different investors
that make up my personal community that
raise
start to finish took me 10 months to
build and complete
in the middle of a pandemic fundraising
is a journey
like i said for me it took 10 months and
those announcements on techcrunch are
always
a celebratory moment but from an
outsider's perspective
or for a first-time founder those joyous
moments can look
a lot like something that is very linear
this very linear path
you decide to raise money you join
accelerator you offshore the races
it's easy they say it's fun they say
it's far from that the reality is this
incredibly volatile experience for most
founders
there are ups and downs that go along
with it and i don't say that from a
revenue or business standpoint
i say this because fundraising done the
wrong way
takes you away from your business and
nothing is more
important than your business